les chercheurs t-il vadimir poutine
comme vient de nous le dire elena
volochine à faire la guerre pour avoir
la paix gulliver crack comment ces mots
sont ils perçus à kiev où vous vous
trouvez
c'est un discours qui a été reçu à kiev
avec un mélange de colère et de terreur
je pense c'est le cas de le dire je
suivais sur les réseaux sociaux un peu
les réactions pendant que j'écoutais le
discours est ce que beaucoup
d'ukrainiens ont retenu c'est que le
président russe questionné vraiment le
droit de l'ukraine d'exister et puis que
son discours était plein
d'interprétation extrêmement
tendancieuse de l'histoire et de
mensonge pur et simple que ce soit le
fait que l'ukraine il a dit que
l'ukraine était une colonie il a dit que
l'ukraine n'avait pas accédé à la
démocratie c'est absolument faux
contrairement à la russie où vladimir
poutine se faire élire dans des
élections qui ne sont jamais reconnu par
la communauté internationale comme un
libre et non faussée ou son opposant
principal
alexis navalni est en prison l'ukraine a
connu cinq présidents depuis que
vladimir poutine est au pouvoir en
russie les présidents perde les
élections et quitte le pouvoir quand ils
perdent les élections pour beaucoup
d'ukrainiens c'est justement cela qui
fait le plus peur à vladimir poutine de
fonctionnement de leur démocratie mais
oui je pense que vu que il a menacé des
conséquences sévères sans préciser
lesquelles vu ce que disent les
américains sur les informations qu'ils
ont sur une attaque imminente de la
russie sur l'ukraine et bien sûr la
concentration de forces russes juste
l'autre côté de la frontière je pense
qu'il sera très difficile pour beaucoup
d'ukrainiens dormir tranquillement cette
nuit s'agissant du nombre à ce qu'a
prévu de faire l'armée ukrainienne dans
l'east dans les prochaines heures
ça on le saura bientôt parce que le
ministre de la défense doit parler tôt
ce soir je sais pas exactement à quelle
heure peut-être qu'on aura des éléments
de réponse à ce moment là jusqu'à
présent les ukrainiens disait qu'il s'en
tenait aux accords de minsk le cessez le
feu préconisé par les accords de minsk
et qu'il répliquait uniquement compte
leurs soldats étaient en danger depuis
le début de l' escalade dans le donbass
qui dure depuis quatre jours maintenant
le regain de violence l'ukraine a
clairement dit que c'étaient les
séparatistes soutenus par la russie qui
en était responsable
poutine lui accuse l'ukraine d'être à
l'origine de ce regret ce regain de
violence il ya plusieurs vues plusieurs
incidents aujourd'hui où la russie a
accusé le des forces ukrainienne d'avoir
traversé la frontière russe ou d'avoir
tiré des missiles sur la russie où
devoir a tué un civil dans dans la
région contrôlée par les forces qu'elle
soutient l'ukraine dément toutes ces
accusations comment est-ce que l'ukraine
peut répondre un conte vladimir poutine
dit qu'il faut plus qu'il y ait une
seule goutte de sang de plus quand pour
l'ukraine c'est absolument les forces
que la russie soutien qui leur tirent
dessus et cette violence a continué
pendant toute la journée d'aujourd'hui
difficile d'imaginer que cela va
s'arrêter maintenant est ce que les
ukrainiens vont maintenant considérer
qu'ils ne sont plus tenus par les
accords de mise puisque vladimir poutine
a dit lui même maintenant que cet accord
et n'est plus valable on va voir il y à
cette crainte que les républiques
autoproclamées voudrait contrôler
l'intégralité des régions de donetsk et
de lougansk alors qu'ils ont contre
seulement une partie pour le moment et
cela voudrait dire repartir à la
conquête de villes comme marioupol cela
vient du kram à tort sq par exemple je
pense que la continuation de cette
escalade dont le das malheureusement est
plus que possible